[Music]
thank you
oh
dude no man
that's we talked about some disgusting
[__] that was the most disgusting thing
that we've seen thus far
sound dude
yeah seriously
that dude if someone if I'm sitting in
someone's house and someone's mom does
that with the eggs
I want four yeah
oh my God I'm doubling my order yeah
like that you are that's disgusting I'll
have seven
your mom is so filthy I want breakfast
every time yeah that's true actually
that's a good point if that was your
friend's mom
your friend would be like mom gross what
the [__] with guests here and you'd be
16 like it's cool yeah I don't mind
yeah I don't know that's cool no no no
chill yeah fine yo shut the [__] up not
sick you have a sick cooking style
I'll do [__] I'll do 15 eggs please I'll
do 45 eggs
we gotta cook eggs like that this
weekend here it's just as honor
sound is crazy doing this weekend Labor
Day yeah uh this weekend Labor Day what
the what the goddamn [__] am I doing
what should I do in Vegas what should I
play
horses for sure anything else uh
actually I'm gonna do high limit slots
yeah I'm gonna do it yeah just just oops
a a 100 spin yeah oh oopsie just one
yeah I just farted
nice okay
[Laughter]
you fart I tried was that a silent one
it was SBD
hahaha
I can't wait till I can't wait till ovie
Lauren put in there two weeks after this
oh my God bro
like these boys are disgusting man
um I'm standing up to just Inspire some
energy
I got none dude I'm fighting off a panic
attack right now yeah
they're just consistent
wait yeah wait hold on this will help
yeah that's that's a social post
right this will help
right yeah yeah oh that's yeah
yeah
did I actually just get you yeah a
little bit
a wee bit
all right well thanks for joining us
yeah for sure
what is this
what what no that's not real what what
no way that's real oh definitely what
yeah it's editing for sure yeah that's
so good man it's so good man
oh my gosh
you know it's gonna be awesome man when
memes in like three or four years
are
like AI VFX
it's all just crazy ass [__] that's not
real yeah that's what our sense of humor
is going to be stupid
oh what
wow the baby's here congratulations
what a way to end it
yeah the end of a podcast the beginning
of a life
years from now this Baby's gonna come
back and look at this episode yeah I
thought you all filmed while I was
giving birth I really I really hope that
it doesn't I really hope that it doesn't
we filmed the fart episode when you were
born yeah
oh my God that's awesome
happy day oh
oh
my god oh that's their feet so they're
like this dude yeah that just took me
out I don't like getting their phone in
their [__] taint I don't like I don't
like this channel anymore man
ew I used to love it not anymore no I
hate it not anymore
peaceful moose sighting
let's end on a good note
it's on the last one there why okay okay
this is actually a peaceful moose
sighting
yeah that's what I thought it was gonna
be
yeah that is beautiful
yeah
well you know what I was reading
why what oh no I was just reading this
book about like you know
they like one of the one like the under
like one of the narratives underneath it
is about a hunting right right and he's
talking about how like people
you hear that and you're like oh that's
wrong
you know you hear about someone like
hunting an animal and you're like that's
[__] up right right but there's an
argument
that like there's a there's a weird like
Paradox that people have developed where
they think about stuff that happens in
nature okay and they think about they
think about it as like just and right
and gentle and nice
when really the way that animals die in
nature nature is super violent yes most
of the time yeah and like torturous
sometimes sometimes they get eaten alive
like an old Caribou for example the two
ways that they die essentially or
normally is they are they're eaten alive
by a predator like a bear right or they
starve to death because they become too
old to get any of the food in the tribe
oh so it's it's those two ways got it so
he's like a bullet to the head or a
bullet to the brain and he dies
instantly he's actually the most humane
way that that animal could be taken out
of the
so I say that to say like the videos we
watch of the moose getting hit by the
car
that's probably one of the most Humane
ways that that thing could die right
[Music]
oh my god dude
it's pretty good
uh yeah I'd say you did take a wrong
turn off the strip
oh yeah yeah yeah
um you're in the casino yeah
you know what's really funny is
some some of these like some of these
Tick Tock interns they're getting caught
up they're doing Millennial jokes yeah
um
an F1 car in a casino yeah so
that's the thing yeah that's a thing
that's a thing
yeah dude you guys are getting caught
yeah dude yeah yeah it catches up with
you fast wait till it all it takes is
one corporate job yeah and you're doing
that's a thing totally
so that's a thing so that's a thing
I make I make memes and stuff
oh that's so bad
meet derp derpin remember Derpina yeah
of course yeah yeah derpenus